Insécurité, fracture sociale, crime organisé,
autant de raisons d'éviter certains quartiers et certaines fréquentations.
Et pourtant, pourtant, le crime est partout.
Là où vous ne l'attendez pas.
Dans votre rue, chez vous, dans votre chambre,
dans votre lit, là ! Tout de suite ! Derrière vous.
Il a un couteau ! Attention ! Meurtre ! Il vous a égorgé ! Trop tard vous êtes mort !
Bienvenue
dans "Au coeur du crime".
André Brasselet est un homme simple.
Employé d'une petite entreprise de gestion de biens,
C'est un homme comme un autre.
Qui va pourtant être la victime d'un crime.
Quoi ?
Effroyable,
un crime inexplicable.
Ah bah oui André, c'est un bon copain.
Un copain qui va malheureusement croiser la route de Rodrigue Jaffret.
Un homme ordinaire qui  va pourtant commettre l'irréparable.
L'arme du crime ?
Yes !
Une simple paire de ciseaux.
Un employé sans histoire, qui va...
Qui va...
Sans crier gare.
Qui va sans crier gare, planter,
les ciseaux, dans le...
Voilà !
Qui va planter, les ciseaux, dans le dos d'André.
Non, franchement, j'ai du mal à croire qu'il ait pu faire ça.
C'est pas possible, non.
Oui bon là, clairement... C'est lui.
Mais le meurtrier ne s'arrête pas là,
Puisqu'il va à nouveau poignarder sa victime dans la cuisse.
Poignarder sa victime dans la CUISSE.
Non, la cuisse !!
C'est la cuisse, ça peut-être là?
Voilà, voilà !
Parce que c'est important la cuisse sinon il se lève et pour le suivre avec les caméras c'est compliqué.
Dans l'entourage d'André, tout le monde est sous le choc.
On pense à la vie, à la mort, aux moments perdus qu'on ne retrouvera plus jamais.
On pense aux enfants d'André bien sûr, aux soirées de Noël sans Papa.
Une assiette en moins à table.
Oh elle pleure !
Zoom ! Zoom, zoom, zoom ! Tu l'as ?
Ooooh, elle chiale !
Tu l'as ? Tu l'as ?
C'est à présent la fin de cet épisode de "Au coeur du crime".
Et souvenez-vous, le crime est là où on l'attend le moins.
Attention derrière vous, c'est le crime !
Non. Mais peut-être !
Méfiez-vous...
Attention !
La semaine prochaine, nous suivrons la fin tragique d'Erwan,
un simple ingénieur du son sans histoire.
Quoi ?
Bonjour Erwan.